Enchant me. Simplify my life.
Make me amazing.
They're incredibly
one-sided wedding vows,
and the three key principles
underlying the Android team's
creative vision for the platform
and the apps that run on it.
As engineers, it can sometimes
be difficult to see past
our own delight at harnessing
the power of an SDK
to bend a machine to our will.
But ultimately, our goal must be
to create that same empowering experience
for our users.
And we do that by creating apps
that are as aesthetically pleasing
as they are functional and easy to use.
Users judge the quality of your app
within the first 30 seconds.
It may not be fair, but,
a disproportionate amount
of that judgement will be based
not on the functionality,
but on the visual aesthetics.
Does it look polished?
Does it look professional?
How easy is it to use?
More than just looking pretty,
the entire user experience
is critically important.
With 30 seconds to win users over,
it's critical that that onboarding process,
that time and effort required
to go from downloading your app
to performing it's main function,
should be as short
and frictionless as possible.
Not only that, but a well designed app
should evoke a visceral reaction
that speaks to the subconscious.
It should be fun to use.
It should surprise in delightful ways
through subtle animations
and smooth transitions that contribute
to a feeling of power and effortlessness.
It should let users touch
and interact with objects directly
rather than having
to use buttons and menus.
And it should use rich imagery
and pictures in place
of lots of words and long sentences.
It allows users to customize your app,
to make it theirs while providing
beautiful and sensible defaults.
Create something that works like magic,
learning your preference in the context
provided by the device,
so it never asks users for information
that they've already provided.
Provide simple shortcuts
to complete complex tasks,
and remember data settings
and customizations
making them available
across every device.
While it's good practice to create
a familiar and welcoming experience
by creating a look and feel
that's consistent
with the platforms, styles and themes,
it's just as important
to remember that this,
and all the other principles
I've discussed here,
are really just a starting point
for your own creative vision.
Deviation from the guidelines
is encouraged, but when you do so,
deviate with purpose.